it has been said that one is the
loneliest number that you will ever know
but at least the number one is a number
that can actually be known what could we
possibly mean by that we'll try to
imagine a number that cannot possibly be
known or quantified a missing number if
you will no not that one this is a
number that you can never put into an
equation or a formula and it does not
appear in the numerical sequence you
cannot count to it add to divide or
multiply by it or even see it and yet
this number still somehow exists sounds
impossible doesn't it after all the
mathematicians among you will understand
that the numbers are not a force of
nature they aren't a metaphysical aspect
of our reality like space or time
numbers are a tool in a way a tool
created by human beings we use them to
measure and calculate numbers help us
make some sense of this crazy world that
we all live in just ask your math
teacher and they'll tell you how
important numbers are to human
civilization the point is ancient
mathematicians invented numbers so how
could a number ever be missing what
makes a number unknowable well perhaps
it's time you learned math class is in
session and today we're talking about
scp-033
also known by the appropriate nickname
of the missing number
as you may have already gathered the
whole point of scp-033 is that it can't
fully be understood by the ordinary
human mind even highly trained
mathematicians experts in the use of
numbers able to understand the most
complex equations are barely able to
interpret the formula that results in
this missing number at present it exists
written down on an irregularly shaped
piece of paper this paper does not have
any right angles no parallel borders and
the length of each side is different
from all others the scp foundation keeps
this paper stored securely locked up at
the minimum safe distance of 30 meters
away from any computer or other
electronic device on the paper itself is
the mathematical formula that equals
scp-033 as you can probably imagine the
formula is intensely complex it is
filled with mathematical symbols ranging
from common ones that you would
immediately recognize to those that are
way more sophisticated and would likely
require a phd to fully understand and
then there are parts of this
unfathomable problem that would baffle
even the world's most notable math
geniuses but all these symbols and
numbers coalesce to equal a number that
has somehow been missed by all of
humanity throughout the entire history
of our civilization one noted
mathematician by the name of professor
hutchinson who first observed the
calculation of scp-033
referred to the missing number as theta
prime okay so here we have a number that
can barely be understood by the average
person created by a formula so complex
that when written down it might as well
be a page full of gibberish surely there
couldn't be anything more to it than
that right wrong you should know by now
that the scp foundation doesn't concern
themselves with the mundane ordinary
type of strange they deal exclusively in
the kind of strange that has anomalous
origins and properties in the case of
scp-033
the missing number is so complex that it
practically breaks every and all rules
of mathematics in other words theta
prime cannot possibly remain fixed
within our reality the reason why the
paper theta prime is written on has to
have such unusual dimensions is due to
the anomalous effect of the number when
written on ordinary paper canvas or any
other similar surface or material the
missing number will begin to break down
whatever it has been written on it will
literally erode and disintegrate
anything on a molecular level you might
be forgiven for thinking you could get
around that by typing out the equation
for theta prime on a computer but you
would be wrong this reaction even
affects technology burning out any and
all devices someone attempts to
digitally store
scp-033 on and if written on literally
anything else well then the missing
number will fade become obscured and
unintelligible in a matter of seconds
unreadable to anyone we've talked a lot
about what scp-033 does mainly because
we can't really show or tell you what it
looks like well unless you want your
computer phone or tablet to break down
and melt from the inside out like we
mentioned earlier theta prime cannot
remain fixed in our reality and it will
fade away from any surface or destroy
any devices used to display or calculate
it but the anomalous effects of the
missing number do not stop there
scp-033 also possesses the ability to
leap from any safe material like the
paper of specific dimensions that it is
written and stored on that is why the
safe containing the paper with the
missing number equations written on it
has to be kept a certain distance away
from any electronic devices or other
surfaces that can display theta prime
should a material safely storing scp-033
come into contact with anything unsafe
say a computer then the missing number
will pass on to the unsafe device
material or surface and begin to
destabilize its atomic structure any
paper or electronic storage device
within a 30 meter safe distance of
scp-033 risks becoming a victim of theta
prime almost as if the number itself is
an infectious virus although the scp
foundation's top researchers have tried
their best to find one there currently
exists no safe way to store
scp-033 digitally the foundation has a
number of projects that are still
ongoing looking into the best possible
method to store the missing number
electronically without posing a risk to
their computer's systems additionally
the foundation has long been conducting
research of a different nature trying to
find some way of weaponizing
scp-033 it doesn't seem like a bad idea
right after all theta prime functions a
lot like a computer virus when it comes
into contact with machines so why
wouldn't they try to use it as a weapon
it is the goal of these projects that
the foundation will be able to use the
missing number as a way to neutralize
hostile machine scps any anomalies that
they encounter that operate on logic
based systems such as artificial
intelligences could in theory be
susceptible to the destructive effects
of scp-033
within the scp archive file for the
missing number is a classified article
that details more about the discovery of
scp-033 before going on to explore the
results of the foundation's testing with
theta prime's use as a cyber weapon of
sorts first and foremost is a transcript
from a debriefing with professor
hutcheson if you were paying attention
earlier then you will remember that this
is the same professor hutchinson that
first observed scp-033
and as a noted mathematician he has some
invaluable inside knowledge on the
nature of theta prime as he calls it
every school child knows that two plus
two is four the solid mathematical
certainty of numerical order and value
is the basis for all logic based systems
we know that after two comes three and
after three comes four what this formula
proves is that we missed a number
somewhere imagine if all our technology
was based on the belief that after four
came six we simply didn't know or
conceive of five that is in essence what
this formula proves we missed a number
the professor then goes on to ponder why
handcrafted vellum works the best for
containing
scp-033 vellum is essentially an older
type of fine parchment that originally
would have been made from the skin of a
calf or other young animal professor
hutchinson seems to theorize that there
are two ways this particular material is
able to keep
scp-033 written on it one the
irregularity of the crafting process due
to human error serves to eliminate any
traces of regularity that would be found
in a machine-created product two the
irregular borders seem to confuse it
somehow as if it gets locked up looking
for a pattern to identify and use as an
escape hatch i'll tell you this though i
don't think it should be left on
anything longer than a few days it will
find a pattern eventually finally
professor hutchinson then goes on to
talk about the anomalous effects of the
missing number specifically its ability
to destroy materials or computers that
it comes into contact with hutchinson
posits a theory that theta prime does
not actually destroy anything but
instead tries to integrate itself into a
system or onto a page but the system or
page cannot cope with the missing number
and so breaks down it is almost as if he
thinks the number itself wants to be
understood it longs for humanity to
understand it after having been missed
for so very very long but theta prime is
so utterly beyond our understanding that
it has the potential to be devastating
it's like trying to cram another book
into a completely full bookshelf if you
get a hammer you can get it in there but
the whole shelf bursts eventually if it
gets out into the internet we will
potentially experience a full i.t
infrastructure collapse within hours
during one of their numerous tests with
scp-033
the foundation's researchers wrote the
various equations and formulae that
equal theta prime on a standard piece of
white copy paper referred to as x1 then
they placed a second sheet x2 just 30
centimeters away from x1 within about a
minute the same mathematical symbols and
formulae on x1 had started to appear on
x2 after 160 seconds the second page was
full with the complex equation for the
missing number after around 5 minutes
both x1 and x2 began to appear slightly
damp however theta prime and its related
equations were still visible on the
pages after double that time the first
page x1 had begun to separate dissolving
partly into water and the rest into the
pulp that had formed the paper itself
while it still kept the same standard
shape and size the formulae written on
it had since become unreadable x2 was
still wet as well but scp-033 was still
visible after over 21 minutes had passed
x1 had been completely destroyed the
water component of it had evaporated and
the paper pulp had also disappeared the
second page x2 soon followed the exact
same process of being structurally
broken down and unmade atom by atom
until there was nothing left it becomes
terrifying to think what might happen if
you wrote the equations for the missing
number on another human being while
their testing has yet to produce any
tangible results the foundation staff
always make sure they transfer the
missing number onto a whiteboard or
chalkboard whenever studying it upon
doing so researchers are instructed to
incinerate the paper that scp-033 was
written on previously preventing
multiple instances of data prime and
hopefully stopping the number from
spreading any further any researchers
observing or experimenting with scp-033
must do so within a safe distance away
from computers and other devices testing
can only occur for a maximum of 42
minutes before the missing number will
destroy the surface it is written on or
fade from view while dangerous volatile
and potentially hugely destructive if it
ever fell into the wrong hands theta
prime is a strangely insightful scp
knowing there exists a missing number
must be similar to how mathematicians
felt about the introduction of variables
you will probably have seen these a lot
in your algebra homework find the value
of x and so on like scp-033
that is also a number that cannot fully
exist in our reality unless you figure
out its value it influences the
calculations you have to make to find it
but it cannot be seen or understood
fully at first perhaps there will come a
day where we can store the missing
number properly but until then we can
only hope it never finds its way into
our favorite notebook now go check out
scp-1861 the crew of the hms
wintershimer and
scp-823 carnival of horrors for more
scps that'll blow your mind